Animal Crossing is getting a new content
update for Earth Day Nintendo is
investigating switch account breaches
and fortnight has an official start date
for season 3
I'm chasity and these are your top
stories for Tuesday April 21st
happy birthday game boy now you're
playing with power this week Animal
Crossing New Horizons is getting a huge
content update and a new event for Earth
Day real world Earth Day is April 22nd
and New Horizons nature day runs from
April 23rd to May 4th
it adds special nuke miles plus
objectives like planting trees watering
flowers and tending to new shrubs April
23rd is also when the next free update
hits which adds some new characters and
the expanded museum art wing you can buy
shrubs and unique seeds from the sloth
leaf we'll set up shop in the plaza when
he visits also you can purchase art and
furniture from red the Fox who's boat
will be docked at your Islands private
beach these artworks can then be donated
to the museum which will now feature a
whole new wing dedicated to art just
when I thought I was putting less time
into animal crossing they pull me back
in I'm pretty excited about the new
museum expansion but what are you most
excited about
next up Nintendo is investigating
reports of switch account breaches some
switch owners are reporting unauthorized
access to their Nintendo accounts it's
not clear how widespread this is but
Nintendo is investigating the situation
in the meantime in tender recommends
using two-factor verification and if you
think your account has been breached you
can contact in Tendo support desk and if
you don't have a switch yet have you had
a hard time trying to get one with the
current shortage let me know in the
comments season 2 a fortnight has been
extended and season 3 start date has
been revealed season 2 a fortnight
chapter 2 is being extended until June
4th which marks the start of season 3
because of the extension epic is adding
quote multiple game updates on the way
that will deliver fresh gameplay new
challenges bonus XP and a couple more
surprises of our sleeve season two's
extension means you have more time to
complete those weekly challenges you may
have skipped the season and if you need
help with those check out our tips and
guides on GameSpot next up deaths
surroundings PC release has been delayed
originally set for a June second release
death surrounding is now coming on July
14th via Steam epic game store and
retail the delay
as a result of the kovat 19 pandemic as
Kojima Productions staff is currently
working from home PC players are no
doubt eager to play the game especially
as the game is strangely relevant right
now but thankfully the delay isn't too
long
what other ps4 exclusives do you want to
see on PC and finally Super Mario maker
two's last update is huge final update
launches on April 22nd and it's
completely free it introduces an
ambitious sounding world maker mode
which allows players to string their
user-created levels together from a
starting point to an end battle in the
castle essentially Nintendo has given
you the ability to make a small-scale
Mario game as up to eight worlds
featuring a maximum of 40 courses can be
put together the update also includes
more items power-ups and new enemies
Koopalings phantom and mecha Koopas I'm
pretty excited that they're adding the
Frog suit from Super Mario Brothers 3
what's your favorite custom level so far
and what new ideas does this update give
you let me know down below that's it for
Tuesday April 21st
I'm chastity and can find me on twitter
@jrfromptc
[Music]